let's go to your voicemails two one nine
two david p is the voicemail number you
can call any time of day if you want to
call it three a.m. you want to call it 4
a.m. many of you do i see the timestamps
you can do that let's take a listen to
this voicemail that came in it hi David
so absolutely groundbreaking news today
with manifold and gates indictments now
I was wondering if you could keep us
updated to see if you still have any
more people lying to you or calling you
about oh there's nothing going on with
with the chrome campaign no we're sure
there's no absolutely no collusion and
most we're here what's up yeah I'm just
interested to see how many people after
this revelation will still believe that
yeah you know those native trumpets
anyways great show look forward to
hearing from you thank you very much
very good sometimes I don't know when
when the voicemails are wrapping up as
you can tell I am still hearing from
people that they do not think there is
any story here I am still hearing on
Twitter the term nothing burger is used
Pat told me this morning he thinks there
is no Trump Russia story everybody
around me no I'm kidding Pat didn't
really say that
people are still saying that there's
still nothing here there are people
mostly on the right but still some on
the left who are insisting there is no
Trump Russia story and I sent out a
tweet yesterday and I don't even know if
I meant it literally or not but I said
if you still think there's no Trump
Russia story and you want to troll me
please just block me and let me never
hear from you again because we actually
have big-boy things to talk about on the
program we've got indictments we've got
all sorts of stuff actually happening in
the real world I don't have time for the
bogus trolling tweets okay so really how
under I I'm at a loss for words
how could anyone think there is no Trump
Russia story at this time unless you
have decided ideologically that you're
committed to the idea that there is no
Trump Russia story on the bonus show
today in the midst of indictments and
guilty pleas related to Trump Russia Fox
and Friends did a very hard-hitting
analysis of the emoji cheeseburger
crisis we'll see where they came out on
that groundbreaking piece of reporting
also can
is having a water problem and they're
considering volcanoes as a water source
and you might be thinking wait a second
well water from volcanoes how does that
work I'll tell you on the bonus show and
much more david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up and get instant
access patreon.com slash david pakman
show can also get you the bonus show
sign up